the pandemic has taken more than 56,000
American lives and one of the most
widely used scientific models from the
University of Washington has just raised
its projected death toll to more than
74,000 the Trump administration is
offering what the president calls a new
strategy to increase coronavirus testing
across the country Ben Tracy is at the
White House met Ben is this actually a
new strategy not really most of this is
a repackaging of things the
administration has already done but with
the promise of more tests really this is
a list of suggestions that states can
follow and the testing is not going to
be a problem at all president Trump's
new blueprint for testing does not set
specific goals or timeframes and says
the federal government should be a
supplier of last resort it still leaves
it up to the states to create and manage
their own testing programs but the
president hopes it will help states
quickly reopen their economies recommend
that they do it as quickly as possible
but safely nearly 14 weeks after the
first reported US cases CBS News has
learned the federal government plans to
send every state enough test kits to
screen two percent of their population
every month overall the US has conducted
more than five and a half million tests
but that's just around 1.6 percent of
the country short of what some health
experts say it will take to safely
reopen schools and businesses you know
is it a nice thing to do yes in recent
weeks President Trump has even
questioned whether a national testing
plan is needed
he says governors told him on a phone
call Monday they're happy with the
federal response and the testing itself
is going very well
no complaints but that's not what some
governors like Virginia's Ralph Northam
and Connecticut's Ned Lamont are
actually saying in order to reopen our
economy we really need that testing and
I'm tired of asking we're working with a
CBS we're working with the big gun labs
we're gonna put together our own testing
protocol and get it done
now some Democratic lawmakers are
criticizing the White House testing plan
senator patty Murray of Washington State
says it will accomplish
nothing new but there's no doubt that we
do need more testing a study out of
Harvard says that by June we should be
testing 5 million people a day and 20
million in July Tony all right Ben Tracy
for us at the White House Ben thank you
very much